Good morning John.
Guess what's behind this thing?
New York City!
And guess what's behind this thing?
It's me.
I'm at home again.
I was in New York because SciShow just got
a big new sponsor, and we we doing press tours,
talking to people, anyone who would listen
to us about science education and stuff.
You may have noticed that we've never, ever
done a branded video here on Vlogbrothers-
this is not one of those.
They don't know that I'm making this video.
Emerson, for the most part, makes stuff that
you would never buy, unless you, like, own
a power plant, or a Fortune 500 company, or
something.
And so the advertisements we're doing together
aren't about getting people to buy their products,
because that's not the problem they have.
The problem they have is that they solve big
engineering problems and big science problems
and to do that they need scientists and engineers.
And with not as many people graduating with
so-called 'STEM degrees,' and more people
going to work for big new companies that you've
heard of like Google and and SpaceX and Tesla,
they're a little worried.
And I share their worry, though for separate
reasons.
I don't hire engineer people- for the most
part, I hire humanities people.
Like writers, and video editors, and artists,
and stuff.
I'm concerned because scientists and engineers
solve a lot of the big problems that we need
to solve, like how do we get clean water to
more people?
And how do we continue to power this amazing
lifestyle that I get to lead without destroying
the world?
So yeah, when this came to SciShow, I was
like, "Oh, this makes sense, actually.
We will do that."
That STEM toolkit is a very valuable one,
and one that is being developed less often
by people.
And what I kept being asked by people on TV
and radio was "Why?
Why are fewer people doing this?"
And I'm not an expert on that; I went through
school one time.
That's pretty much all my data.
But as with most things, my guess is it's
a lot of different reasons.
And one reason is that I think it's really
hard, and we just kind of sugarcoat it sometimes,
but it is hard, and that's huge amount of
information to stick into your brain.
But I think, more than that, we're also told
that there's a certain type of person who
becomes a scientist or an engineer, and they're
just good at it.
They're just good at math, and they're good
at science, and just engineering geniuses!
And that's a really dangerous myth, because
everyone I know who went through a science
or engineering degree, it was really hard
for them.
It was really hard for me.
Nobody is born being good at math.
I think some people are born really liking
that challenge.
That's the thing that all of the scientists
I know have in common.
Like, there's no other common trait amongst
them.
They're mothers and rock climbers and punk
rockers.
Some are into politics, or sports, or spend
their evenings on Tumblr.
The only thing they have in common is that
passion for solving hard problems.
And there are certainly non-science problems
that need to be solved as well.
That's why I hire lots of artists and animators
and video editors and stuff.
I think often when we tell people to get into
STEM careers, it's not because it's interesting
or fascinating or cool, it's because that's
the best way to get a good job, so do that.
If you don't do this terribly difficult thing,
then you will never get a good job.
And I think that's a terrible thing to do
to a child, who is like fifteen years old.
They're in high school, and you're telling
them, "Okay, just start panicking now.
A decade before you will be done learning
all of these things."
That's-that's terrifying!
We can't we, instead, treat this like every
other big problem and take it one step at
a time, being driven by not the end goal,
but by, you know, interests, and fascinations
along the way.
And I wanna say the most interesting toolkit
you can have is one that includes both and
technology, engineering and liberal arts.
That's the education I had, and I'm so grateful
for it.
Anyway, this really is a career path that's
open to everyone.
So that's why I was in New York; I was doing
things with them.
And seeing lots of my friends and hanging
out with cool people, that was fun too.
The advertisement we made together, just encouraging
people to be interested and fascinated by
science, is running now.
There's also a link below -- you can see it
on YouTube.
And if you're thinking to yourself, "Hank,
you were in New York City and you did not
tell me and I did not get to see you that
is so uncool," I was very busy.
But also, I will be back!
In April!
With Harry and the Potters, Driftless Pony
Club, Andrew Huang, Rob Scallon, playing music
all, from like Chicago, all the way to New
York, there's like eight stops.
You can check out more information in the
link in the description.
Tour Because Awesome: East Coast!
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.